let's get back to you the audience via
discord
davidpakman.com
discord so that we can learn from people
let's try steve from the bay area again
steve you bailed on me when i went to
you at the top of the show but you are
back i'm sure now you have a great
question for me
hey david i'm really sorry about that it
was my first time calling in i got a
little nervous what didn't have a
question ready but now i do i hear it it
almost sounds do you have it written
down i thought i just heard a piece of
paper shuffle
oh i'm just moving a bag of food oh okay
um anyways
so i'm probably one of those random rare
people that is a progressive and a
christian as well okay and i know a lot
of people including myself have a bad
taste in their mouth over the
evangelical right
and uh there are i just wanted to let
you know that there are a minority of us
sadly we are a minority that uh is
fighting for you know the actual love
and
of our neighbor as as jesus talked about
so um
i'm just wondering um have you met many
christians that like are on that side of
the progressive uh like bernie vibe and
and uh what's your experience with them
yeah you know i'm i haven't met hundreds
but i've certainly met a and know in my
personal life
one to two dozen people who are
progressive christians we've interviewed
some progressive christians uh yeah also
progressive i mean i guess progressive
catholics is more common catholics i
think tend to be more left than
certainly evangelicals i guess i would
say uh no but i know i know born again
christians who are
left i don't know that they're bernie
necessarily but they're certainly on the
left and uh soon we're actually our
friend benjamin dixon is doing some
great work from within christianity to
fight christian nationalism he's a
progressive christian
and uh yeah it's not uh it's it's not
the rarest thing in the world
yeah for sure
um i i really follow an organization
called red letter christians and they
really try to focus on kind of the words
that jesus said in the bible and whether
you believe it or not and that's fine um
i know you're not particularly religious
um but you know there are
those of us out there who read the bible
for ourselves and are like uh maybe we
should actually do those nice things and
treat people with with respect and not
push our beliefs on others now where are
progressive christians like you on
abortion
um i am pro-choice interesting and what
is the scriptural justification in your
mind um i don't think there's i don't
think the bible even discusses abortion
okay so it's just the bible's a
non-issue to your view on abortion
yeah i think that overall there's more
good done to um to support abortion
rather than you know stick people that
would seek one usually for financial
reasons because they kind of you know
can support one yeah that's about half
the time um
and why would we assume those people
should bring up children and and
you know saddle them with that kind of
burden and stuff so and most of them
happen in the first trimester anyways
when i don't really think that's a life
i mean it makes a lot of sense to me and
then how about on gay marriage
my brother's gay so
and he's married and um
i mean
i guess if i if i was pressured i'm
probably like
you know
anti-gay marriage personally but like i
would vote against it i guess um and i
love my brother and i support him and i
know that probably sounds bad too like
you wouldn't get a gay marriage but
you're okay with other people doing it
yeah well i like i like girls but um
right no but i i understand i also have
a lot of empathy for people who do have
attraction to the same sex because i
know if i was in that situation it would
be really tough and i i don't know if i
if i how i would square that with my
faith so i'd have to uh personally
figure it out you you i'm guessing from
what you're saying you don't think
people choose to be gay
no definitely not yeah yeah all right
well very interesting i appreciate your
insights
all right thank you all right there we
go progressive christians very very
interesting